*NOKIA™ SOUND*
*PICKS UP NOKIA™ UNIVERSE S7™*
It's me
Mr. PewDiePie
It's Google™
Google™?
Google™, you called at last
Now tell me, tell me about the secret algorithm. You promised..
Once I hit 50 million
You would tell me everything
"I need more power !" - Pewdiepie 2016
I'm running low. JackSepticEye (Irish Potato Fucker) is catching up
I'm falling behind, GOOGLE™
WHAT YOU WANT LILLY SINGH ON TOP (Insert dirty joke here)
*HOLDS NOKIA™ UNIVERSE S7™ SEXUALLY CLOSE* That's right. I know you don't
Now that you finally made it to 50 million subs
You have access to a super secret higher level of Youtube Heroes
Youtube™ Super Saiyan™ God™ Level Hero™ (all rights reserved to GOOGLE™)
Youtube™ Super Saiyan™ God™ Level Hero™?
What is the key information?
Listen closely to this information
Ok
The likes
They don't do anything (wat)
It's a dead button (watt)
It's been a dead button (....)
all along ( *very manly gasp*)
The dislikes
*dramatic Royalty Free music*
What about the dislikes?
Don't you see? That's the key
The more dislikes, The more power (OHMYGAUUUUDDDD)
How do you think so many shit channels can rise to the top?
GhostBusters
Rebecca Black
JustinBieberVEVO
Call of Duty: Dead Franchise (press f to pay respect)
So you're telling me
If I get more dislikes
You will become more powerful than you could ever imagine
*PUTS DOWN NOKIA™ UNIVERSE S7™*
It will be done
*PTSD INTENSIFIES*
*Breaks desk by slamming a NOKIA™*
AYE YO WHATS FFFFFFFFFUHHHCKING GUUD (seizure starts)
1 MILLION DISLIKES!!
CAN WE SMASH IT?
PPPPLLLLLTTTT
1 MILLION DISLIKES. OR I'LL DROWN MYSELF.
*Unnatural cry only comparable to a thousand mating whales*
(SOMEBODY PHOTOSHOP THIS)
BAAAAAAHHHH
1 MILLION DISLIKES!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
*A wild PeedewPee appears carrying it's native instrument*
*Mating call of a million savages*
1 million dislikes
or Romanian dies
(rest in piss forever in piss)
Maya you're so cu-(drugs kick in)
1 MILLION DISLIKES!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!! (my ears omg)
*sexy moans while dabbing*
*Proceeds to binge*
*AHHHHHHH*
(fell harder than Humpty Dumpty)
1 MILLION DISLIKES!!!!!!!
CAN WE GET 1 MILLION DISLIKES? (Yes senpai, now stop asking)
1 MILLION!
*Swedish Hardcore Rap* (Best music ever played)
*They see me rollinnn.... They hatinnnn*
WE STRIKE AT DAWN!
1 MILLION DISLIKES!!!
1 MILLION. No! No! No *regrets decision made*
*Be careful Pewds*
ONE...
1 MILLION DISLIKES !!!!!!!!!!!!
1 MILLION
CAN WE GET. 1 MILLION ???
1 MILLIONNNNN !!!!!!!!
1 MILLION!!!
DISLIKES!!
CAN WE GET 1 MILLION DISLIKES?
Dislikes
I like likes
(alrighty then)
She likes likes
Bet she likes leafy too
1 MILLION
DON'T LOOK AT ME (we're staring at u actually)
HHEEEUUGHH
*sobbing*
(ayy what's good bro?)
1 MILLION Dislikes (jump scare lol)
*fade to black*
Alright so apparently
Likes doesn't mean shit
We've been liking videos
for nothing
fantastic (oh the irony is strong here)
Now it's all about watchtime
and making you keep watching more videos
No one really know what's going on on YouTube anymore
Everyone is just.. testing out different things
begging for likes. Oh that guy got a lot of..
a lot of views
I must beg for likes as well
Well apparently, likes doesn't even do ANYTHING
except dislikes. Don't forget to dislike
What YouTube want is watchtime
and that you watch more videos
That's all they really care about so
Speaking of which, why don't you check out this video
This is a REALLY great one that I think you will REALLY enjoy watching.
Cause it's very.. It's practically the same video as this one
Oh my God
I'm getting too old for this shit (nah)
Don't forget to dislike the vide-
sub to me